- And by the way, by the way, real quick.
- [Person On Phone] Mhm.
- I don't expect any of
you to take this advice
cuz it's too scary.
(laughing)
But I really hope I can
inspire one of you to do it
because it's exactly how you
get a job at Vayner Media
which would be a much
better place to get a job
than any other agency in this city.
(heavy drum and bass music)
(Skype call rings)
Hey guys
um
so thanks for having me in class.
A couple things that are
running through my mind
that I wanna start with.
First of all
I think
when you start talking
about digital and social
it's super important to understand
that
um
it's really about attention, right?
It's not necessarily digital or social.
I'm not overly romantic or
passionate about Facebook
or Instagram or Skype or
Youtube.
Uh
to me it's just where do
I think the attention is
and where do I think that it's overpriced
and where do I think
that it's underpriced.
And my fascination with
digital or social is
a lot of it is underpriced
but to be very frank a
lot of it is overpriced.
When (censored) is a market
and that other people
have to deal with in big companies is
they have to measure things
and put them into data and reports.
And what I have the
luxury of is to trade on
intuition and
um, and
other cultural variables
that give me my decisions.
Plus, I'm running a marathon
while a lot of people
are running a sprint.
What I mean by that, class, is
I don't have to pay under to
the short term profit margins
that big companies and
small companies have to
because I'm not incentivized
by dollars in the short term
I'm looking for the long term.
And so, what does that all mean?
It means that I've been very passionate
about being historically correct.
Whether that was Email
or search or YouTube
or Twitter or Facebook or podcasting or
whatever it may be.
And so, for me it's very binary
very black and white.
What's a good use of my time
and money and what is not.
As we sit in this room today
there are certain things that overindex
and certain things that underindex.
So for example
digital.
I can love digital
but I know none of you are watching
the majority of prerolls
that you get targeted by
none of you are clicking on banner ads
none of you are carefully reading emails
none of you want spam texts in your texts.
You're not excited about ads
that are being read to you
broken up when you're
listening to Pandora.
Um
you definitely don't like a midroll ad
when you're watching YouTube vlog
and all of a sudden there's
a car ad in the middle
with this shell that's super
shocking, it makes no sense.
So there's a ton of terrible digital.
At the same token
I think everybody's going
through their feeds on Facebook
and uh Instagram
and that they are grossly
underpriced for now.
I think a lot of you will
start to tune out feeds
in a decade
but for now it's super underpriced.
And that's because the
biggest brands in the world
don't spend enough
money in these channels.
Pepsi or Toyota or BMW or GE.
I just don't think they spend enough
in Facebook or Instagram.
And you have to understand this
unlike other digital properties
like VICE or Refinery29
where there's
where there's a basement of costs.
There is none of that
on Facebook and Instagram and Snapchat
because they're marketplaces, right?
So.
If you go to a publisher like
Turner or CBS or BuzzFeed
there's a minimum threshold
before they'll work with you
because they're running a smart business.
But on Facebook
all of us can run $7 worth
of ads on there, right now.
We can all run $7 worth of ads right now
and I think that's a very big deal.
Very important to understand
because when you understand the market
the aspects of the market
and what a true marketplace is
it leads to overpriced
and underpriced variables.
There's good and bad deals.
And so things I'm spending
my time on right now are
Snapchats are being left for dead
yet the ad product is really underpriced
for people under 30 in America.
If you're 40 to 70 on Facebook
you're a very good target for ads
very inexpensive in my opinion.
Um
you know
Instagram's incredible
for culture 18 to 35
very underpriced, the ad product.
The influencers on Instagram
are unbelievably underpriced
for 18 to 35.
18 to 45 on the coasts,
15 to 35 in the middle.
Um
so
I'm just completely passionate
that digital, if you wanna call it
is the right answer for
a lot of you in this room
to do marketing and build businesses on.
I'm just warning that 80% of digital
can be spent on garbage.
And so I think the landmine
that you guys need to be thinking about
the landmine that you guys
need to be thinking about is
is it a good deal or a bad deal
and that's what I would spend
all my time on as a marketer
and as an executor in this environment.
And I think there's a
big disconnect between
the best and the worst.
I think the best comes
from entrepreneurs that are
you know
stuck.
Good entrepreneurs
cuz a lot of entrepreneurs
are terrible at marketing
but good entrepreneurs that are stuck
and need every penny to work hard.
And I think the worst are
the biggest brands in the world
that have tons of flush money
and are just mailing it in
and are putting a lot
of money in bad places.
So that is my thesis, class
and I'd love to answer some questions.
- [Woman on phone] Creative, as well as
making sure that they're
the most receptive
which is why we're
investing in a lot of merch.
You mentioned there were
some limitations, right?
I also worked for a boss that
worked the EPIC film, right?
So we've talked here about the trade off
between long form and short form content.
- Yeah, so class.
Long form, short form.
It's a very big debate
and it makes a lot of sense to Linda and I
we're in it every day.
But let me get to the punchline.
There are shitty six second vines
and I would watch a
seven hour Star Wars film
because it's Star Wars.
I would say that the length
is far less a variable
than people make it out to be
because we need to talk more about--
we need to talk more about
the quality of the content
in the context of the platform.
So, in an ideal world
um, you know
we would make incredible
content that's a minute
minutes of great context.
Great little stuff.
I love three minute videos
if they keep your attention
I love six second videos if
it can get the point across.
It's a variable
but it's been very overstated
in debating the length.
To me it's--
to me it's the context of
the content to the audience
that it's targeting.
This is a pretty gangster move.
The Skype started not working
so I'm just gonna get
a quick tweet promotion
of the new episode going.
[Skype Rings] That's better!
- [Linda, Via Computer
Skype] Yeah, okay, so ready?
Here's the class again,
you can see everybody.
I asked them in advance to
think of questions for you.
So we're gonna see who has a question.
- [Parker] Hi, what's going on.
Big Hot Ones fan, Gary, nice to meet you.
My name's Parker and this is Ryan.
So I wanted to ask you
specifically about transparency--
- Yes.
- In regards to digital marketing.
So on platforms like
Instagram, Facebook, YouTube
do you think going
forward that transparency
is the most important thing
just so that the advertisements
that they're putting up there
can function as they're suppose to?
- So--
- Also, going along with that
just wanted to say
cleanest bones in Hot Ones
- Yes, yes.
- Cleanest bones.
- I love it.
Uh
thank you for that.
Literally being known as
cleanest bones by YouTube
is greater than being on the cover
of Entrepreneur Magazine
so thank you for that.
(laughing)
So let's define transparency
because people throw it
around in a lot of ways.
How do you define, what's the rub?
What do you think the rub is?
What are you focused on?
- Right so for Facebook
I know it's really important that recently
they announced that they were
going to start announcing
that the ad is from a Russian source.
Or on YouTube I know there's a big scandal
back in like early 2010, 2011
when uh, Microsoft was paying YouTubers
but they weren't announcing it.
- Oh I see.
Yeah I mean look, look.
I think, I think that
on the surface
everybody in this class is gonna be like
yay transparency, right?
I think in real life
everybody in this classroom
would be devastated
on how much they don't give
a shit about transparency.
Like, like.
Humans are very funny, right?
We talk about things
lemme give you an example.
Everybody loves to talk
about the environment.
In this class, everybody
in this class right now
when I talk about oil companies
would be like boo, right?
(class laughs)
The sweater that you're
wearing right now, bro
which is super fashionable, good job.
- Do you know how many people died
to make this sweater?
- It's not even that
do you wanna hear something interesting?
- Sure.
- That company is doing a
ton worse to the environment.
Textiles is destroying our environment.
- I believe it.
- Do you think everybody in this room
wants to give up their
Yeezy's and their Supremes?
(class laughs)
So
lemme tell you what I think.
I think that 90% of
the stuff we talk about
doesn't match our actions.
Right?
So, I think transparency is
super important for up side
not down side.
I think what it's
what's good for it
puts hashtag ad
is that it gets the benefit.
I think that nobody here
would do real fucking research
to figure out the Microsoft YouTube thing
that nobody gives a shit about.
- Okay. Thank you so much.
- You got it.
- [Linda] Alright let's
go to the next row.
- Let's do it.
- [Man On Computer] Hi, Gary.
- Hi Guys.
- We share a birthday, I'm a huge fan.
- Thank you.
- So question.
I know you're a huge Knicks fan
and the idea this year
is they introduced the
sponsors on the jersey.
And so I, myself, am a big NBA fan
I'm also a huge cycling fan.
So cycling teams are do
or die, sponsors are named
after everything.
- Yep.
- So do you think
obviously the Big Four has sponsors
but do you think this is a trend
that we're gonna see continued
where sponsors are on the jersey
or sponsors are on the helmets--
- Yes.
- You do?
- Yep.
- Where do you think it's gonna go?
How far do you think it's gonna go?
- I think the NBA jersey in 16 years
could look like a soccer jersey.
- Interesting.
- I think, I think
I think it's gonna be a game of
some sports are gonna go
with the WalMart model
and some sports will go with
the kind of Cartier model.
Right?
Like I could see the NFL doing one logo
like the NBA right now
uh
and I could see the NBA
going with six logos
and baseball being two
and hockey being one
and you know.
We also have to figure out in 20 years
you know
esports and MMA and
things of that you know.
The Big Four, hockey's
not a Big Four, right?
- No, not anymore.
- And so, how does it play out?
Like baseball took all
the short term money
by creating BAM.
None of you can find a
YouTube video or Instagram
about baseball
and that's gonna play
out in 20 years, right?
And, and has football hit its apex
because of politics and concussions.
So, you know, fuck the Big Four might be
esports, soccer, uh MMA
you know and basketball
and then this conversation goes
into a whole different place
cuz the other three you have fresh slates
and it was really only about the NBA.
Which is ironically, weirdly, intriguingly
the one that's starting with it.
Right?
- Yeah. Perfect, thank you so much.
- You got it.
- [Linda] Next row, anyone?
- [Girl] Hi!
- Hi!
- Hi Gary!
- Nice to meet you!
So most of us in this class
are studying marketing as our degree
so we're doing a lot of
interviews for internships
so do you have any tips for interviewing?
- Uh
for the interview itself?
- Yes like through it
for a marketing position.
- Uh
I would tell you the number
one thing you should do
is be disproportionally honest.
I think the biggest mistake
that people make in interviews
is they play a part.
None of you and I mean none of you
are actually gonna act normal
in any of these interviews.
(group laughs)
Let me tell you why.
I'd rather you not get any jobs
than to have to keep up a
facade inside that place.
- That makes sense.
- It's kind of like die
by your sword, right?
Like, be you.
Like, be you and be like
Look, I'm giving you
advice that I've taken
and being front row seat to this.
A lot of more people are comfortable
with the things I'm saying today
than they were six years ago, right?
And a hell of a lot more
are gonna be comfortable in six years.
Right?
So when you're in these interviews
and people start asking you questions
I don't know, I don't care,
or I think that's ridiculous
are answers none of you guys are gonna say
and I think they're the
actual right answers
that can start your career
off in an incredible way.
- Okay.
- And by the way, by the way, real quick
I don't expect any of
you to take this advice
cuz it's too scary
but I really hope I can
inspire one of you to do it
because it's exactly how you
get a job at Vayner Media
which would be a much
better place to get a job
than any other agency in this city.
- [Linda] And I agree with it.
I hire for authenticity.
I don't want somebody playing a role
that somebody's gonna
bring a diverse perspective
to my team.
- And that's exactly why guys.
You may get somebody
who is like (censored)
like why am I doing this?
I get asked by all my clients to do it.
It's because she's an outlier
for the right reasons.
And so you can go to (censored)
where she is
or you can come to an
entrepreneurial place like I am.
But like
you just wanna die on your sword.
You're gonna give them answers
that you think they want to hear.
So when they bring up something
that you don't believe in
but you learned in this class
you're gonna answer with the class notes
and that's a mistake.
You need to go with what you believe.
Now you may not know.
Don't just blindly believe
that Snapchat's awesome
but like
if you believe something
you have to die on that sword.
- [Linda] Are you saying
I don't believe everything I teach them?
C'mon Gary.
- I definitely believe
that to be the case.
I also
and what I think is more interesting
is I have all the advantages
because of Hot Ones and
Instagram and all the things
and they don't believe
everything I'm saying either
and that's the point right.
Let them like
they should die on their sword.
Not if I've got a moment
in time where I'm cool
and then blindly parrot what I say.
Or, they respect the
system or your history.
Like they just need to
form their own opinions
and answer on those opinions.
- [Linda] Alright, front row?
- [Josie] Hi Gary.
- Hi!
- I'm Josie thanks for chatting with us.
I wanted to know
you're really great at forecasting
kind of what the next big
thing is in the marketing world
and you express augmented
reality to be one of those things
so I was just wondering
if you see any current leaders now
in what we call an augmented reality?
- It's a Facebook and Snapchat
world when it comes to A.R.
The only thing I see
that's interesting in A.R.
is the way that they're
playing with filters
and kind of those kind of things.
The fact of the matter
is everybody in this room
is really gonna like when
an A.R. is really good.
Like imagine you can
literally take 35 minutes
cuz software's that good
to post an Instagram post
of you dancing with your
sixth grade boyfriend
because you literally took a photo of him
where you can manipulate it.
Like the level of creativity
that A.R. is going to allow us
is gonna be so remarkable
but the leaders are Facebook and Snapchat
because of what they've been buying up.
The startups they've been buying up.
Um
and then you gotta look
at Apple and Google
because they own the phones, right?
So they make it default
when we take a photo
well that's an interesting
arbitrage, right?
So, you don't need an app
it's just part of the phone.
So
I think it's gonna happen in mobile
I think long term it's gonna
happen in contact lenses.
I think you especially how young you are
will live a life where
your brain will control your contact lens.
In essence your brain
will control your new eye
and you will switch from real life
augmented reality
and to virtual reality.
A mixed reality world
where you can have the choice.
Like how awesome would it be in this class
when (censored) is a little bit boring
for you to switch something
and what you're actually doing
is living in a virtual reality world.
And so, I think that's cool.
- I hope contacts don't get banned
cuz I actually need that stuff.
- I don't think they're gonna get banned.
I think, I mean.
I think
you wanna talk about radical transparency?
I'm so happy for you and all
the other women in this class
in seven years we're gonna know
that you might be livestreaming right now
through your contact lenses.
(laughs)
I mean it
I have a funny feeling that's gonna have
one of the great impacts on our society.
- Thank you.
- [Linda] Last question?
- [Man #2] So quick question.
In your opinion
what's more valuable
interning with say, a start
up who's just getting going
or someone who, even a startup
who's grown more than the other ones.
Or actually starting your own start up
and starting your own company
even if it fails.
- Um, 100% predicated
on the person's ability to be self aware
and understand who they are.
If you're an entrepreneur,
start a company and fail.
If you're not, the first one.
- Alright. Perfect.
- [Man #3] One more Hot Ones question
cuz I can't not ask.
How hot was the last dab?
- Was that the third to last one?
Or the last one?
- Last last one.
- Not even remotely close to
hot as the third to last one.
- That's what everyone says.
I tried it recently. My brain melted.
(class laughs)
- They go by that scoring system right?
- Yeah, scovilles.
- As somebody that grew
up in the wine business
where you know a wine could
get 95 points, 92 points
I promise you
that
they misrated those last three wings.
- Wow, what's the best ones?
- Those, I loved seven.
The one right before insanity.
(men exclaiming)
Dude you guys really need to
question how hardcore you are
about hot ones.
I'm just kidding
I'm kidding, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- I've wasted so much time.
I analyzed your video for this class, too!
- I appreciate it, thank you.
- [Linda] Apparently I need to watch this.
- Oh it's really good, Linda.
You're gonna like it.
- [Man #3] It's the smartest
talk show available right now.
- [Linda] Alright, one last
question. Back on topic.
- Yes.
- [Linda] So we've talked
a lot in this class
about social influencers--
- Yes.
- Credibility, reach, amplification.
And I think Vayner has a
really unique point of view
on how to leverage them.
So can you talk a little
bit more about that.
- Yep. So class.
I think it's one of
I think it's about inefficiencies.
Facebook is inefficient
because Pepsi, BMW should
be spending more there
which means it's cheaper.
Got it? Very simple.
Humans are the more
inefficient thing in the world.
So.
Influencers are super interesting.
For example
some people think they
should get $5,000 a post
because they bought a ton of
fucking fans on Instagram.
Right?
Ludicrous.
Meanwhile, on the flip side, an alpha mom
right?
A woman in Shore Hills, New Jersey
that is the alpha mom
that affects 400 other
woman of high income
around products and services
may want $100 for a post on Instagram
and it's worth 10 thousand, 50 thousand.
Got it?
So we need to treat it like media.
So for example
if I was, if I was (censor)
who's becoming culturally irrelevant
I would buy 78 thousand
people on Instagram.
Not three personalities.
I don't think about influencers
like endorsements, right?
Or spokespeople.
I think about influencers
as in buying media, right?
Scale
and buy 78 thousand people efficiently.
I think it's an incredible opportunity
especially for the people in here
that are starting startups.
You can hit real pay
dirt with influencers.
- [Man #4] So just to clarify.
It's more about contextualization
within the field
rather than that cache.
You'd rather have a
person that has a blog--
- Both. Nope. No.
- I would love Kim Kardashian
if she's willing to be underpriced
and she fits my brand.
Got it?
- Okay.
- So I think there's cache in both.
Again, the number one PTA mom in St. Louis
is the number one fucking
PTA mom to those 700 people.
So, I think the cache is
contextualized, right?
Like for example.
You guys
like the thought that a
42 year old business man
would've been cool to people in their 20s
five years ago would've
been laughable, right?
But I have figured out how
to contextualize myself
to make myself relevant
to you guys, right?
While that wasn't me manipulating it.
It was riding the wave of entrepreneurship
being put on a pedestal.
And then, I got lucky
because I grew up in an environment
that was a little bit more urban
I was a shitty student.
I had some level of swag
that made it authentic
for me to go on Hot Ones
and be able to talk about
Post Malone or Cardi B or Lil Xan.
You know what I mean?
- [Linda] I think it goes
back to what you said
at the beginning
around getting the right
value for your money, right?
- That's it.
- Some are overvalued,
some are undervalued
but depending on your business objectives
what your brand is trying to do
and making sure you get the right reach
in the right context.
- To that point, class.
I think the Super Bowl
is the number one deal
in marketing.
Right?
That's not digital.
That's a tv commercial that I
like to shit on all the time
but I think it's the best deal
because everybody sees it.
Whether you see it on
YouTube or you watch it.
All of you
at your young youth
will watch the Super Bowl ads.
Forget about you being in marketing class
four years ago, six years ago
when you were in high school
you still saw the Super Bowl ads.
That's incredible penetration awareness.
- [Girl #2] Can I ask you
a question about that then?
- Yeah.
- Has been telling us she is
not going to be running the ad
and since you guys run her company
what do you think about that then?
- I think that they should
run Super Bowl, right?
But we don't plan their media
we do their creative
so that is against my strategy.
Now, just so you guys know
for all the coolness
that's going in my life
I don't think I'm right about everything
but I really, really, really do believe
I'm very passionate about
our strategy on Super Bowl.
- Thank you.
- [Linda] Thank you so
much for your time today.
We really appreciate it.
- Thanks, Linda. I love you.
Take care.
Bye class.
This is the coolest.
♪ They gon try and freeze,
when you heatin up ♪
♪ They gon hold you back
cuz they aint keep up ♪
♪ But you never let 'em
in, never let 'em in ♪
♪ Stay out the way, fuck
errbody, keep goin ♪
♪ I said stay out the way ♪
♪ Fuck errbody keep goin ♪